>> Greg: AS HALLOWEEN
APPROACHES MEDIA CLOWNS ARE
OUT IN FULL COSTUME IN
HYPOCRITICAL OUTRAGE
ACCUSING EVERYONE ELSE OF
GINNING UP ANGER.
HOW YOU BE SO COARSE, THEY
REPLY.
MY RESPONSE, CRAM IT YOU
JERKS.
LET'S REMIND TWO MONTHS THE
KAVANAUGH HEARINGS OUR
MODERN WITCH TRIAL WHERE WE
WATCHED A MAN GET DESTROYED
BEFORE HIS FAMILY ENABLED BY
A SALIVATING HATEFUL MEDIA
SLIME PACKAGED BY WELL-OILED
MACHINE.
ACHE SAYINGS GROSS.
NOTHING CLOSE AS EVER COME
FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
AS WOMEN IN COSTUME
SUGGESTED A FUTURE WHERE
KAVANAUGH WOULD ENSLAVE AND
BRUTALIZE WOMEN.
LEFT WING NUTS CRASHED THE
HEARING.
OUTSIDE THEY HOUNDED
REPUBLICANS.
BY DEMOCRATS.
THOSE DEFENDING DUE PROCESS
WERE GRANDED ABUSE ENABLERS.
AN ENTIRE PARTY TRIED TO PIT
GENDER AGAINST GENDER.
>> IT'S THE MEN OF THIS
COUNTRY.
I WANT TO SAY TO THE MEN OF
THIS COUNTRY SHUT UP AND
STEP UP.
>> Greg: WHAT WOULD YOU CALL
THAT RHETORIC DIVISIVE,
HATRED.
NBC MIGHT HAVE SAD ON THE
INFO DISMISSED THE CLAIMS OF
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
NBC HAD THE INFO FOR WEEKS
ABOUT A WITNESS AVENATTI
GAVE TO THEM INSTEAD OF
BACKING JULIE SWETNICK'S
ALLEGATIONS ACTUALLY DENIED
THEM.
ALSO ACCUSED AFTER NETTIE OF AVE
ALSO ACCUSED AFTER NETTIE OF AVA
ALSO ACCUSED AFTER NETTIE OF AVT
ALSO ACCUSED AFTER NETTIE OF AVI
TWISTING HER WORDS.
NOW A DAY BEFORE HALLOWEEN
THE SAME BLIND SELF-OBSESSED
MEDIA WHO AIDED ONE OF THE
UGLIEST SPECTACLES IN RECENT
HISTORY KNOCKING AT YOUR
DOOR DEMANDING SOUL
SEARCHING FROM YOU AND ME.
THEY PRAY YOU DON'T REMEMBER
BUT WE DO.
SORRY, NO CANDY FOR YOU
KIDS.
GET OFF OUR PORCH.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSE, THIS STORY IS
INTERESTING AND IT'S NOT
GETTING A LOT OF PLAY THAT
NBC WITHHELD EVIDENCE THAT
WOULD HAVE DEBUNKED THIS
MYSTERIOUS WITNESS.
JUST KIND OF WENT AWAY.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY ARE
GUILTY OF COLLUSION WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE ACCESS HOLLYWOOD TAPE.
THEY HAD TRUMP ON CAMERA FOR
10 YEARS SAYING WHAT HE SAID
AND DROPPED IT THREE WEEKS
BEFORE THE GENERAL ELECTION
VERY SUSPICIOUS TIMING.
THEY ALSO SPIKED THE RONAN
PHARAOH EXPOSE ON HARVEY
WEINSTEIN THE PARENT COMPANY
HAD A BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP
WITH WEINSTEIN STUDIO.
CORY BOOKER STORY.
CORY BOOKER WAS CREDIBLY
ACCUSED OF FORCING SOMEONE
TO PERFORM ORAL SEX ON THEM
RECENTLY.
THE ALLEGED VICTIM WENT TO
RONAN PHARAOH AND HE DIDN'T
TOUCH THE STORY.
I'M WONDERING WHY NOT?
DID IT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH CORY BOOKER BEING A
DEMOCRAT SNAND, TWO, MAYBE
WE SHOULD USE THE KAVANAUGH
STANDARD FOR BOOKER.
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN
INNOCENT.
THE MEDIA TELLING YOU TO
TONE DOWN THE RHETORIC?
I MEAN, THAT'S LIKE AN
ALCOHOLIC TELLING TO YOU
STOP DRINKING.
IT'S LIKE, NO, YOU ARE THE
DRUNK.
YOU'RE THE DRUNK.
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN SAYING
THE PRESIDENT IS MENTALLY
ILL RACIST NAZI RUSSIAN
TRAITOR WHO NEEDS TO BE FROG
MARCHED OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE CALLING HIS DAUGHTER
THE C WORD AND HOPING HIS
SON GETS RAPED.
AND NOW YOU ARE MAD BECAUSE
HE CALLS YOU FAKE NEWS IS
THE ENEMY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
YOU GUYS CAN DISH IT OUT BUT
YOU CAN'T TAKE IT.
>> Greg: I THINK WE GOT SOME
NEW VIDEO OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
JUST ARRIVING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PITTSBURGH
MEDICAL CENTER RIGHT HERE.
I DON'T SEE HIM BUT.
>> Dana: THERE ARE FOUR
POLICE OFFICERS THAT ARE
INJURED AND BEING TREATED AT
THE HOSPITAL AND THEN SOME
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
THERE.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S GO TO THIS DANA.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THIS.
NBC CLAIMED THAT THIS WAS NO
LONGER A STORY BECAUSE BY
THE TIME THIS INFORMATION
HAD COME OUT, HE WAS
ALREADY -- THE CONFIRMATION
HEARING WAS OVER SO FORGET
ABOUT IT.
>> Dana: I READ THE
EXPLANATION KATE SNOW WAS
THE ANCHOR AND REPORTER THAT
DID THE INTERVIEW.
SO YOU HAVE TO READ THE
EXPLANATION LIKE THREE OR
FOUR TIMES AND IT STILL
DOESN'T QUITE MAKE SENSE WHY
THEY WOULDN'T WANT TO KIND
OF OWN UP TO IT RIGHT AWAY
AND SAY WE HAD THIS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW.
THEY DID CERTAINLY JUMP ON
IT.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS HOW
MUCH OF THIS BACK FIRED?
NOT JUST NBC BUT BILL HEMMER
TALKING ABOUT FIVE KEY
SENATE RACES WE ARE GOING TO
WATCH, ONE OF THEM IS
INDIANA.
I WILL ACTUALLY BE THERE
TOMORROW.
THEY SAY THE ACTUAL MOMENTUM
FOR THE REPUBLICAN ONLY TIME
HE PULLED AHEAD IN THE
ELECTION WAS AFTER
KAVANAUGH.
>> Greg: JUAN, DO YOU THINK
THE COUCH STORY HAD
THE KOUCH STORY HAD
THE KAVCH STORY HAD
THE KAVAN STORY HAD
THE KAVANAUTORY HAD
THE KAVANAUGHRY HAD
THE KAVANAUGH S HAD
THE KAVANAUGH STOAD
THE KAVANAUGH STORY HAD AN
EFFECT BECAUSE THEY SAW THE
OVERREACH OF THE DEMOCRATS
ON THIS?
>> Juan: THE STORY HAD A
DEFINITE EFFECT IN TERMS OF
ENERGIZING REPUBLICAN
VOTERS, THE BASE OF THE
VOTERS.
YOU SAW THE SPIKE IN TERMS
OF THEIR ENTHUSIASM POST
KAVANAUGH NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR
NOT THAT ENTHUSIASM HAS
DISSIPATED AND WHETHER
PEOPLE ARE STILL REACTING.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN JUST IN
THE LAST WEEK IS A DROP IN
THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
RATINGS, EVEN BEFORE THE
SHOOTING TOOK PLACE.
I THINK IN SENSE A QUESTION
IS HOW MUCH DO REPUBLICANS
STILL LOCK IN TO THAT MOMENT
AS A DRIVING FORCE, A SENSE
OF GRIEVANCE.
LET ME JUST ADD IN TERMS OF
THE NBC STORY THAT KATE
SNOW, THE REPORTER STANDS BY
HER REPORTING.
AND I MUST SAY I THOUGHT
WHEN SHE INTERVIEWED
SWETNICK, IT DAMAGED
SWETNICK AND IT DAMAGED
AVENATTI.
I KNOW YOUR PERSPECTIVE,
GREG.
I'M JUST SAYING WAIT A
SECOND IF YOU WERE ON THE
SIDE OF SAYING HEY THERE IS
NEW HERE AND DAMAGING TO
KAVANAUGH.
>> THE PROBLEM IS NOT BEING
DISHONEST.
>> Juan: SHE IS SAYING HE
DIDN'T SPIKE THE PUNCH.
SHE NEVER SAW ANYBODY LINING
OUTSIDE THE DOOR TO ASSAULT
WOMEN.
I THOUGHT IT WAS HELPFUL TO
KAVANAUGH.
>> Lisa: KATE SNOW IS NOT
BEING HONEST NEITHER IS NBC.
THEY SPOKE TO THE SECOND
WOMAN END OF SEPTEMBER.
LAST TEXT MESSAGE EXCHANGED
WAS OCTOBER 5TH WHEN THIS
WOMAN ACCUSED AVENATTI OF
TWISTING HER WORDS.
AND STILL TO THIS DAY WE
HAVE NO CORROBORATING
WITNESSES OR EVIDENCE
SUPPORTING ANY OF OF THE
CLAIMS FROM CHRISTINE FORD,
DEBRA RAMIREZ OR JULIE
SWETNICK.
EVEN MORE NEFARIOUS THAN
THAT YOU LOOK AT THE, WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF EMMA
BROWN THE REPORTER THERE
EVER HAD FORD'S NOTES.
SHE WROTE IN HER COLUMN OR
HER STORY, RATHER, THAT SHE
RECEIVED PORTIONS OF THEM.
THAT CHRISTINE FORD
TESTIFIED UNDER OATH THAT
SHE WASN'T SURE SHE GAVE HIM
THE NOTES OR JUST SUMMARY OF
IT THEN YOU GO TO THE NEW
YORKER STORY, DEBRA RAMIREZ
HERSELF SAID SHE WAS VERY
DRUNK THAT NIGHT.
SHE WAS ON THE FLOOR.
SHE DOESN'T REMEMBER.
RONAN PHARAOH ONE OF THE
AUTHORS SAID THAT DEMOCRATS
WENT OUT SEEKING THE STORY.
JANE MEYER WOULD TELL ELLE
IN THE ME TOO ERA IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH A
PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR.
THAT'S WHY THEY AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUED THIS STORY FROM
DEBRA RAMIREZ.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SAID
THEY INTERVIEWED SEVERAL
DOZEN PEOPLE AND COULDN'T
FIND A SINGLE EYEWITNESS TO
CORROBORATE THE STORY OF
DEBRA RAMIREZ.
YOU HAVE THREE STORIES
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE, NO
CORROBORATING WITNESSES.
YET, THE MEDIA WAS HAPPY TO
RUN THESE STORIES TO DAMAGE